this is such an awesome moment i
interviewed john cameron mitchell i just
talked to him and he's so excited that
this show is finally coming out and of
course he was raving about you two it's
her first dramatic role i think she
really knocked it out of the park
i wish i had more scenes with her that's
so nice he crushed it as well yes
how did it feel for you to be doing
something on this scale for the first
time
i mean it was a it was a leap for sure
you know most of the things i do last
three minutes and this lasted eight
hours and uh so it required a lot more
prep than i'm used to but kyle was very
instrumental in um
helping me i just learned so much just
watching you and the way you approach a
scene and
how he did it it's scary to to try
anything new but you got to keep trying
stuff you know
you know what that's a very carol baskin
thing she never said
the truth i will not rest until abusers
like joe are kept as far away from
animals as possible
like you can keep me away from my
animals we will see damn right we will
what was the transformation
moment reaction from you and by that i
mean the first time you see yourself in
the mirror in the carol wig in the in
the garb how did you feel i couldn't
access the character on any level until
i put on
that wig baby man is that
hair makes the man and i just was like
yes now i can feel it because she has a
mane she has cultivated a mane of her
own
and um i felt suddenly so imbued with
her spirit you know you moved
differently too when you had the wig on
when you have a clue now carol has kind
of that how she kind of says a little
sway with her body you move completely
different with that with the hair
because you have to do things to
accommodate it you know you have a so
you have a nice mane there thank you i i
wondered what the weight of the wig was
that's a lot of hair
it was you know it's light it's it's
it's fluffy but it's yeah it was
something it wasn't
i really think he's evil howard i have
to get him how are you gonna do that
let's think of something together kyle
uh as she just said i have all these
amazing scenes with you um what was it
like to work opposite this woman one of
the most challenging difficult
extraordinarily
um well because i hit and bite you know
yeah and scratch um
we had it was such
such a pleasure
um first of all she's the most available
actress one of the most available
actresses i've worked with very present
ready to go
very committed very very um
uh intent on
the character that she has and what
she's doing but willing to play and
improv and
move through the scene
in a different way in an unexpected way
than what's on the page
um so we we were very creative within
our little our little working space
um and we were it was encouraged by the
directors i think they let us do a play
a little bit um came up with some
wonderful stuff and she just is again
she's so brilliant so inventive
it was exciting it sort of like we were
stepping off a cliff every time we did a
scene and it was really fun i mean well
you too and we and we danced i mean we
actually danced as well but it it felt
like a dance and their relationship is
so
beautiful to me in real life and i it
was just so easy to cultivate that with
you because it's you're so easy to live
thank you well you know i have to ask
did you speak at all to the real carolyn
howard in preparing for this we did not
however there is so much available on
youtube that they've put there in their
own words and um sometimes that's even
more useful and so we both did a lot of
research and watching them
speak for themselves and then use that
to create these characters how will you
feel if they watch the show what would
your message to them about it be oh gosh
i hope they enjoy it and i hope they see
that their love is reflected in it and
that their values are reflected in it
yeah and their partnership i mean
they're they're partners you know and
they have respect for each other
and even in when things are you know
challenging and not challenging it's
like they still
value each other value each other's
opinions
um it's a it's really a it's really a
partnership and and a loving partnership
i i think we got that
hopefully hopefully see that
she's waiting kyle she's waiting for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
please
look of course we were all so obsessed
with the docu-series when it came out
were you two both as obsessed initially
in quarantine i watched it i i was
obsessed with it yes i because i'm
obsessed with these people i'm obsessed
with people who are real-life characters
and these are larger-than-life people
and i always need to understand
what's underneath
what were their childhoods like what
what drives them what what makes them so
obsessed with cats and what and how are
they coping with life using cats i also
wanted to reach deeper and
um and see what was really driving them
and i think that's
why we did this show i actually
interviewed carol for dancing with the
stars and it was a i know
but it was a real moment to hear her say
hey all you cool cats and kittens hey
all you cool cats and kittens what was
it like for you to say that line for the
first time oh my god it's a nice moment
of trip right because you have the yeah
it takes a moment for her to find
the right words yeah
it was they made it they made a thing
out of it it was good it's different
from doing an impression on a sketch
show um you can't sort of like
do that level of impression the whole
time but with certain lines that were
that are now iconic i just sort of
watched youtube a bunch and tried to
sail it on through how many pieces of
cat print clothing do you think you wore
while filming this show our incredible
costume designer amelia gabler just
found everyone that has been
manufactured on this good globe in the
last 20 years or whatever man there were
a lot of there were a lot of different
pieces didn't she source the one the
real one she got the real shirt that uh
carol wore in the documentary in her
introduction
it was it was an incredible sartorial
journey that i got to go on i don't wear
cat print in real life i just wear cat
hair
[Laughter]
on my pants and shirts and socks and
hair and
everything i own
um kate real quick we do have to ask you
about a different project uh you are
reuniting with margot robbie in the
barbie movie
i mean
amazing
what are you excited about for this
project um i can only tease that i'm so
excited it's going to be incredible
greta gerwig obviously is an amazing
writer and director and margot is
flawless fabulous and i'm just so happy
to be a part of it
and kyle we have to ask you about one of
your most iconic roles the new dune has
come out did you see the new dune and
what did you think i did i saw it i saw
it in australia we had a screening in
brisbane i had an overwhelming sense of
nostalgia which is sort of odd
listening to the scenes and sort of
remembering and and watching them and i
was smiling from ear to ear was really
um
you know uh it was really fun when
timothy puts his hand in the box i'm
like i know that box that's gonna hurt
don't do that
but he didn't listen to me of course
they've been playing the original a lot
more on tv now i've noticed
they have been i know it's sort of given
it a little bump which is fun fun to go
back man we were young oh yeah you ate
thank goodness you still love justice
thank you my darling you don't think i'm
too tan wow i i love you two have you
formed your own relationship making this
show haven't you i love you
again john cameron mitchell raved so
much about the both of you what was it
like to work with him and how did you
react when you first saw him as joe
exotic oh my god i know i mean he really
he got the look obviously but john
cameron i'm i'm such a fan of his from
so long ago and he's such
an incredible performer and philosopher
and such a live wire and i knew he was
just going to
soar in this role and he he did even
beyond what i imagined
i remember hearing that he was cast and
going oh my god that's absolutely
brilliant perfect it's like yes done
that one you can check off your list and
he delivers 100 percent we only had i
only worked with him we had one one
scene together
um which was lovely uh we had a
great time together and i just wish that
we'd had more he's
he's just so talented and again he
delivers something i think really
special in this
[Music]